Ucrania ha tenido hoy Una madrugada
donde volvieron a ver ataques en grandes
ciudades especialmente en Nicolás en el
mar Negro y aquí donde nos encontramos
en la ciudad de klamatos la ciudad más
importante de la región del Don Bass en
control de las fuerzas o del gobierno
ucraniano aquí a las 4 de la madrugada
cayeron cuatro misiles todos ellos en
unas plantas industriales una de las más
grandes de Europa en maquinaria allí nos
cuentan que la destrucción fue grande no
hay acceso a los periodistas porque las
autoridades locales dicen que cada vez
quedan acceso a este tipo de plantas o
construcciones los rusos vuelven a
atacarlos Así que fue otra noche de
miedo aquí las autoridades dicen que
esta ciudad que está de cierta manera
más lejos del frente de batalla que
otras importantes de la región como
eslovians sigue siendo atacada
permanentemente Desde hace dos semanas
lo que hace tener obviamente que la
guerra vuelva a aproximarse aquí las
autoridades piden a la población que
abandone está creando alternativas
instrumentos para llevarlos a una ciudad
cercana a la ciudad de allí hay trenes
humanitarios hasta otras partes de
Ucrania donde el gobierno tiene
destinado darles apoyo Porque aquí
también temen que si se queda No
solamente la guerra se aproxima sino que
también será un invierno bastante duro
porque en este momento no hay gas en la
ciudad